let's say we have a finite geometric
series and so we can denote it like this
the sum from n equals 1 to n equals k of
a
times r to the n minus 1 power and i'm
going to denote this finite series as s
sub k so i'm adding k terms of a
geometric sequence together
and if i wanted to expand this out this
would be a
times r to the 0th power which is just a
r
plus a times r to the sorry a times r to
the 0th power is just a i actually just
write a times r to the 0
plus a times r to the first plus a times
r squared all the way we keep going plus
a times r to the k minus two plus a
times r to the k minus one this is a
finite geometric series
now i want to figure out if there's some
easy way to express what the sum is as a
function of k
and to do it i'm going to do a neat
little trick i'm going to multiply both
sides of this equation right over here
by our common ratio r so let's do that
so we have r
times s sub k
is going to be equal to what well just
multiply all of these terms times r
so a times r to the 0 times r is a times
r to the first so it's going to be a
times r to the first a times r to the
first times r is a
times r
squared
a times r squared
times r is going to be a times r
a times r to the third power
a time then we're gonna keep going so
let me just be clear what i'm doing
then i'm just gonna keep
going
a times r to the k minus two times r is
a times r to the k minus one and then
finally let me make sure i have some
space here
finally a times r to the k minus 1 times
r is a
times r to the k
so all i did here is i multiplied all of
these terms times r and you could one
way you think about it just incremented
all of their exponents all of their
exponents by one
interesting enough but now what i want
to do is cancel out a bunch of these
terms and the way i'm going to do it is
by subtracting the green stuff from the
yellow stuff this is equal to that and
this is equal to that the both sides of
the screen equation are the same so if i
subtract the right-hand side from the
right-hand side and the left-hand side
from the left-hand side i'm subtracting
the same thing from both sides so let's
do that let's subtract so we're going to
subtract this and we're also going to
subtract this which is analogous to
distributing a negative sign so let's
distribute distribute a negative sign
right over here and figure out what we
get
so on the left hand side we're just
going to get s sub k
minus r
times
s sub k and it's going to be equal to on
the right hand side and this is where it
gets neat
this is where it gets really neat we're
going to have a times r sub 0 which is
really just a r
sorry not a times r sub 0 a times r to
the 0th power which is just a times 1.
so that's going to be a
so this just drops down this is just
going to be a
and then these are all going to cancel
out they're all going to cancel out all
the way so that all we're left with is
minus a times r to the k power so
minus
a
times r
to the kth power
and now we can actually solve for our
sum we factor out an s sub k
we get an s sub k times 1 minus r
is equal to this stuff on the right hand
side and over here actually we can
factor out an a is equal to a times 1
minus r sub k
and now we just divide both sides by 1
minus r to solve for our sum divide both
sides by 1 minus r and we are left with
s sub k
is equal to
a
times 1 minus r to the k power all of
that over 1 minus r this is a very very
very this is a very very very cool
result
because someone might ask you what is
the sum
what is the sum
from n
equals 1 to n equals let's say n equals
50
of let's say 5
times
1 3
to the n minus 1.
so in this case our k is 50
our k is 50. a is five a is five our
common ratio is equal to one third and
so we can just substitute back into this
formula that we just derived to figure
out what the sum is you don't have to
literally type all of this stuff into
our calculator you just have to type
this thing right over here into your
calculator
so this is going to be equal to
so in this case it's going to be equal
to
a
5
times
1 minus
1 3
1 3 to the 50th power
one third to the 50th power all of that
over one minus one third all of that
over one minus one third and you could
just type this into your calculator and
get what this exact sum is which is a
lot easier than summing up 50 terms
it's much much easier you could imagine
if this wasn't 50 if instead this were
500 so then this would boil down to this
right over there so anyway this by
itself is cool and we will build on this
to figure out what the sum of an
infinite geometric series might be equal
to